the VVD will not co-rule in the new cabinet
hi i am annabel and i am justice reporter
and in this video I tell you everything about the VVD
and why they are not going to rule
and new cabinet
Milan Jesse goes just now
let us know
to the nos that she does not want to rule
in the new cabinet
the reason for this would be the 7th loss that the VVD
has driven
in response
of the past parliamentary elections
this is very interesting for coalition building
because with whom will the PVV now form 1 coalition
there is a good chance that the PVV
now wants to work together with smaller parties
however, then the question is
whether the other parties still feel like it
namely have parties such as the nrc and the CDA
want to work with 1 party
as for about democracy
it is very interesting now which coalition will come
because it was not really intended that the VVD
would withdraw
what do you think the new coalition will be
let us know